what up space fame goes in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the craziest and latest chapter
of the one piece story and wow this
chapter is so full of craziness
including mihawk's bounty crocodiles
bounty every straw hats new bounty
sabo's return and much more so make sure
to stay tuned for this one it's amazing
if you do enjoy these one-piece reviews
and want to keep them coming you know
what to do channel parking with it and
smash that like button with no mercy be
a smashing pirate king rather than a
passing orochi and youtube will always
reward you with wato fireworks make this
the video you subscribe if you haven't
already and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece videos and updates
now i want to thank today's sponsor
dislike do you guys still remember the
dope game that i collaborated with in
may now they're coming back with a much
stronger esper you guys probably already
know that i'm a big fan of this
turn-based mobile role-playing game that
brings gods of ancient greek chinese
norse and egyptian mythology into a
modern trendy world for instance you may
find that anubis is now a candle expert
and a dog-headed gentleman as someone
who loves mythology this game is a dream
come true with so many cool
myth-inspired espers to collect and
battle with but the big news this time
around is zeus zeus was one of the first
espers to gain power and he along with a
few others formed the esper union
focused low-key and discreet zeus
believes that he and esper union will
solve the mystery of these miracles and
save the world zeus is a very strong dps
esper who is able to switch from his
normal state to his hype god king state
zeus not only looks dope and is able to
control the power of thunder he is also
the only hero that has the unique god
king mode which made him more powerful
than many other espers almighty zeus
awakens is what many will be screaming
soon as the rate of summoning zeus is up
only during this activity so now is the
time to download the trendy futuristic
mythology rpg dislight through the link
in the description and the pinned
comment and use the code esperunion to
get incredible gifts if you have
downloaded this light please reopen it
through the link in the description and
use the code esperunion to get
incredible gifts and nice to see you for
extra homecoming gifts you definitely
don't want to sleep on almighty zeus's
awakening
and now without further ado let's jump
into it spoilers and all this chapter is
called new emperor and although there
will be luffy moments the title i think
is referring more so to buggy this time
around as we see in detail how he became
the new emperor and the leader of both
crocodile and mihawk the strongest
swordsman in the world by the way just
to get the hype going even more shanks
is brought up twice in this chapter both
times in very interesting ways so we
have that to look forward to as well i
must say this chapter over delivered
with the jam-packed awesomeness so at
first we catch up with the straw hats
where nami has beaten up luffy and is
chastising him for recklessly
endangering their lives with the unsafe
descent from moana it's funny because
luffy's emperor title is totally
juxtaposed with him looking pathetic as
he's being chastised by nami showing
that nothing has changed in terms of
team dynamics even if this is a yonko
crew now which is comforting in its own
way jinbe is the one who tells her to go
easy on luffy since no one was hurt but
he quickly gets scared by nami too who
clearly runs the crew with an iron fist
it goes to show even if nami isn't as
strong as she's important for as she
puts it keeping luffy and his stupidity
on a tight leash jinbe even wonders if
nami has conquers haki from the look of
it after witnessing her anger which i'd
assume was a joke but with one piece you
never know for sure what's a joke and
what's foreshadowing especially when the
straw hats are involved meanwhile
frankie is bragging about how well the
sunny held up after the drop saying they
only busted a small yard on the mast i'd
assume that kid in law had even worse
damage but we don't find that out
finally we get the moment we've all been
waiting for the reveal of every straw
hats bounty and i'm conflicted as i'll
get into there is definitely some hype
here with these being called the updated
bounties for the leaders of the 5 600
man grand fleet emperor strawhat luffy
and his nine commanders so awesome to
see all our straw hats being called
commanders at this point now that we are
a yonko crew chopper as the commander
pet has the ongoing joke that he has a
low bounty and the joke continues as
chopper the cotton candy lover as he's
called only went from 100 berries to 1
000 berries even chopper is mad it
barely went up but from here the
bounties get pretty high from lowest to
highest nami has a bounty of 366 million
which she freaks out about since she
knows that even she would go after
someone with such a high bounty brooks
is 383 million cyborg frankie's is 394
million but he's upset since the sunny
is on the poster not him although in my
view he should be happy his skilled
creation made it on at least and is
being appreciated in a way sniper god
usopp is now 500 million and he is
depressed because like nami he knows it
makes him a target and he begged please
no more don't go higher i think he's
actually scheduled for an epic fight
this upcoming arc and then his bounty
will really skyrocket whether he likes
it or not although i think he'll be more
cool with the new one because he'll
embody more of that brave warrior of the
sea ideal that he's aiming for robbins
is awesome at 930
million and yeah it's not all about
power with robin we know that but let's
not get it twisted she was super strong
against black maria and i feel like she
should get more respect strength wise
than she usually does i also love how
she doesn't even react to her bounty as
she's more concerned with just making
chopper feel better about his own low
bounty such great waifu material right
here lastly we have the big three aside
from luffy namely sanji jinbei and zorro
now this was totally predictable so i
will take zero credit for calling it but
zorro has surpassed sanji once again and
sanji is predictably upset sunshi's
actually below jimbei as well as below
our pirate hunter zoro right now still
it's hyped that his bounty is over 1
billion at 1 billion and 32 million
jimbei is 1.1 billion while zoro is
barely ahead at 1 billion 100 million 1
100. still zorro more than deserves it
and my issue with these last bounties is
that like luffy's they really should be
higher after defeating king and queen
zoro and sanji's bounties deserve to be
higher than theirs and yet they are not
which makes no sense to me but i guess
we just gotta accept that they lowballed
our boys this time around and will have
to wait for another round of bounties to
be satisfied finally again we get
luffy's bounty of 3 billion as he's
proclaimed the fleet captain emperor
straw hat luffy even as he's
pathetically beaten up and trapped in a
cage and whining about being hungry
meanwhile sanji is fighting because zoro
called him number four and zoro
hilariously tells him to mind his tone
around the crew's second as a zoro stan
i must say it's good to see him back in
second where he belongs now we jump to
the very good buggy part of the chapter
we find out that buggy isn't the
undisputed leader of the organization
yet as some people may have thought in
fact he's crying and saying he'll do
anything even lick crocodiles boots
clean which it must be said is not
pirating energy like with luffy in this
chapter his title of emperor is
contrasted with a very unemperor-like
situation crocodile then gives us some
much-appreciated explanations he
explains that cross guild was supposed
to be under him and mihawk which makes a
lot of sense he asks so why is buggy
considered the boss buggy says he can't
do anything but apologize while mihawk
says buggy is probably the only person
in history to become an emperor after
crying for mercy he adds that having
buggy die here wouldn't even begin to
make up for this crocodile says it's
beyond insulting and when buggy begs to
be spared mihawk tells him not to make
unreasonable requests which is a pretty
hilarious line i must say galdino who is
not so loyal to buggy tries to get in
crocodiles good graces by saying it's so
nostalgic to be serving him again and
although buggy is upset by this we can't
be surprised since galdino's always been
looking out for his own best interest
and we definitely saw this during the
impel down prison break buggy's top
followers also consider joining
crocodile since buggy is clearly a goner
too saying it's a cold harsh world out
there we then get a much appreciated
flashback as to how mihawk and crocodile
teamed up as we guessed the marines kept
swarming mihawk's island and yes mihawk
could deal with them but it was a
nuisance and he thought he'd have to
relocate and in the flashback crocodile
explains that is why it would be good
for them to team up the navy wouldn't
take an organization headed by them too
lightly so in reality this organization
was supposed to be headed by the
partnership of crocodile and mihawk
rather than by buggy which makes a lot
of sense especially when we get into
these guys as bounties we also get a
hype detail that they use to refer to
mihawk as the marine hunter compared to
zoro the pirate hunter which is a cool
parallel right there as well the two
find common ground and precisely the
fact that they have trouble finding
common ground with others they are the
same in that they don't trust anyone and
that's enough to get mihawk considering
the deal buggy for his part remembers
how he was gonna make a run for it when
the marines came for him until the
warships were attacked by crocodile this
led buggy's followers to assume that the
rumors are true crocodile is working
under buggy and thus risking his own
life to help buggy we get another
hilarious misunderstanding that inspires
loyalty and buggy's followers meanwhile
buggy knows crocodile must be here
because buggy owes him a lot of cash
even though he's broke he thinks to
himself that this is even worse than the
marines which is pretty hilarious
despite calling crocodile croco-chan
buggy is not having much luck at first
crocodile wants his money since he's
forming his own company buggy offers to
join and help crocodile's company he'll
serve him as a former warlord he'll work
twice as hard to pay his debt and he's
pretty correct when he says it's always
good to be flashy and get the word out
with a bang he points out that he has
connections that can help with
advertising printers couriers and so on
he says they can be worked to the bone
for free and so that is how the poster
that emphasized buggy in the boss
position got made and spread around
crocodile holds the poster up calling
buggy mr president ironically he's not
happy and in buggy's defense it wasn't
deliberate his men just loved him so
much they made him look like the leader
and the world believed it we even see
how he was shocked when he saw the final
product but it was too late since the
flyers were already sent out we even see
how the navy interpreted it they call
buggy the mastermind of the mass escape
from impel down a member of the pirate
king's crew which led to a close bond
with emperor shanks and they got
confirmed reports that crocodile came to
his aid when he attacked those marine
warships they also know that crocodile
and mihawk have made contact so it makes
sense after everything including the
poster that they think buggy is more
dangerous than he actually is it's even
pointed out that their new marine
hunting movement has already gotten
financial backing from a number of shady
organizations and again i gotta say the
marine hunting aspect is one of my
favorites in the story so far i
absolutely love that twist the marines
say that with the rebellions they're
already dealing with cross guild is
undoubtedly a massive threat so they
accordingly give these three high
bounties crocodile the actual mastermind
gets the lowest bounty out of the three
at 1.965 billion berries for his logia
ability and cunning guile which is still
way ahead of zorro so when it comes to
the top three in this organization
bounty wise this yonko crew is stacked
in reality crocodiles would probably be
even higher if he wasn't overshadowed by
buggy then we get the crazy moments
we've been waiting for for like 1 000
chapters we get a bounty for mihawk it's
also stated that he has even greater
sword skills than emperor shanks which
is implied in the name greatest
swordsman but still crazy to hear it
spelled out like this again it doesn't
say he's stronger but the statement
still suggests he'd win in a clean sword
fight against ayanko which is
unbelievably hyped and it's reflected in
his insane bounty as a non-yonko his
bounty is a crazy
3.59 billion berries that's almost as
high as shanks and when you consider
they think he's buggy's underling and
not a yonko leader it's not hard to
picture that mihawk could potentially
even have a higher bounty than shanks if
he was at the head of a yonko crew it's
speculation obviously but it's still so
insane to have someone like mihawk
around who has a higher bounty currently
than three of the four yonko and he's
not a yonko himself this chapter has
definitely gone a long way in adding
even more respect to mihawk's name which
is good because i think most don't give
him the respect he deserves then because
of all the reasons we covered and the
fact that they think buggy got mihawk
and crocodile to yield to his authority
buggy got a bounty of
3.189 billion higher than luffy's but
interestingly enough not higher than
mihawks this is like if zoro's bounty
was higher than luffy's man this chapter
is such a flex for mihawk i gotta say
and i'm loving it and although it didn't
show buggy in the best light we can't
deny buggy's superpower of being lucky
and being able to weasel himself out of
practically every situation i do love to
hear though that the world government
considers buggy an extremely dangerous
individual even as bounties have now
clearly ceased to be an accurate gauge
of a character's actual power not saying
they were especially accurate before but
it's clearer than ever that they are not
now especially after luffy and zoro got
so lowballed now i love mihawk here he's
the one that eventually decides that
it's not that bad having buggy as a
figurehead he has no interest in the
title of emperor he just longs for peace
and what mihawk wants crocodile seems to
go with mihawk decides to let buggy have
the target on his back and adds that
they can dispose of him if the need
arises crocodile says it's true and then
we see buggy acting as leader and saying
they formed cross guild to prepare for
the new age he then introduces the new
executives crocodile and mihawk buggy is
crying because he's so unsure of what
will happen to him while his men assume
he's moved to tears because he's so
happy or something and they say they are
moved to tears as well we then catch up
with the revolutionaries as if this
chapter wasn't already hype enough most
people like me believe in sabo however
dragon says he's glad sabo is okay but
if he truly murdered king cobra then he
won't forgive him no matter what his
reasons this is definitely building the
mystery and a possible rift between
dragon and sabo who's become arguably
more famous as of late in the world of
one piece it's nice to see kuma freed in
a panel but it is sad hearing him just
talk like a slave saying i'm yours to
command master even koala tears up while
witnessing the scene we then jump to the
marines who are picking up a call that
is in fact sabo the flame emperor
calling the revolutionaries the manga
asks us will we find out the truth and
we're told we have a break next week but
wow what an amazing chapter to go on
break with this was amazing 10 out of 10
in my view even if i am a bit salty
about luffy and zoro's bounties not
being higher still the mihawk
awesomeness was so good this chapter it
arguably made up for it let me know your
thoughts on the chapter and how you
would rate it channel the parking within
and smash that like button if you
enjoyed this review and want to keep
them coming be a smashing pirate king
rather than passing orochi and youtube
will reward you with wano fireworks make
this the video you subscribe if you
haven't already and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next one-piece video
and chapter to drop feel free to check
out my giant and growing one-piece
playlist that includes videos in all the
yonko admirals warlords mythical zone
users and much more link to that is in
the description and on screen right now
and until next time see you space
cowboys